good morning so this week is the week of
the big conference happening in Europe
called the EGU which are normally great
we're going to but some I'm like my
thesis
so I'm we're not sure stuff to this week
more fool them because they're gonna
miss the greatest achievement
my entire PhD
you ever have something a little bit
overconfident enough but I feel like a
little bit of optimism doesn't hurt
anyone
basically recently I've come up with
this idea for what's missing from my
code by the way I have heard very
clearly you guys want to code they're
here so I will be doing one I'm quite
sure what how yes
but yeah that is coming so this week and
specifically today I'm going to be
implementing what I think's the missing
just gone well so far yet to get a
result out but getting there I have now
in call my house the practice rooms on
campus because music's starting up again
I've actually got a gig tonight which
I'll be taking you along with me which
is singing yeah I'll tell you later
normally when I'm in the practice rooms
I tend to talk about the week ahead but
I'm literally nothing no clue there's no
organized stuff this week so it's as new
to you as it is to me but I can say that
as you may have already noticed the blog
is changing
[Music]
so it's very soothing efforts will never
say Dubai know exactly why I just come
home to think about what I'm going to do
next and do a little bit housework I
figured that I'm gonna be singing in my
own clothes they may as well not be
really really creased and stuff so it
turns out we actually we actually own an
ironing board I didn't even know I
needed an iron for like eight years
oh god I'm doing this fire so what I'm
getting rid of about eight years of
creases from the shirt I mentioned that
the Box can be changing the vlog is now
on going to read nothing but the finest
ironing content Oh
oh it's a scene oh you'll see nothing
but a fine Italian content no basically
the episodes are going to be getting
shorter as you probably noticed but it's
gonna be the same amount of content Co a
week maybe a little more but basically
it's split into smaller videos before we
talk about that more though I've got to
be some singers
well briefly rehearsing at the Cathedral
we got a gig at half past six
I got emailed the music that we're doing
three hours ago and I'm doing a solo
by the time you've been a chapel for as
long as I have this is this is pretty
standard to be honest
[Music]
rustled up dr. Jones was just impotent
how long have you been back in Exeter
Gela five minutes thing even wrote in to
sing hava no ghost in about five minutes
[Music]
[Music]
well that went well mrs. Ashley the
chair I was singing in the very first
ones logs where big camera died so this
is what it looks like on the inside this
is a 950 odds year-old church in the
middle of town which is a second oldest
chest next there is an older one it's
also wonky because that way straight and
that way is not it's that they didn't
have enough land or something like that
it's a key little church anyway I was
talking about this lock so I asked my
supporters on patreon about changes that
I wanted to add to the blog and you guys
seem to like the idea of me splitting
this video up into smaller chunks
so this log into like kind of probably
closer to 10 minute chunks because let's
face it a 40 minute vlog is kind of
intimidating especially to people who
are kind of coming across my channel for
the first time so I thought it'd make it
a bit more user friendly to split these
videos up and also because it gets me
more views because I'm a massive sellout
but there are other reasons like it
means there's more content going out
regularly which helps YouTube's
algorithm the more stuff you post the
higher your ranked and recommended
videos or stuff like that so yeah that's
the reason why
vlogs are going to change to shorter
videos same content just split up and
exactly as last time I'm stuck in a race
against time to try and finish off the
new crash course and we're done
voiceovers recorded final edits done and
it's even and nice Oh
[Music]
[Music]
there is an absolutely beautiful day
next this morning I've been stuck in the
office doing some inversion work which
I'm going to talk about later but first
if you happen to be on this part of
Google Street View on X University
campus by the a memory building I think
you might see me ha never seen one in
the wild before first where I'm going
for a swim
we'd live through the walls and filling
them hey sister very kind of bleed if I
told me swimming said you're going to
see any other one la roca um there are
very few things better in life and
swimming in an outdoor pool there's many
bright sunshine this is how you spend
your lunch break you've got them to look
at that alien abductions in the pool so
they're actually two pulls on campus
there's the outdoor one which is here on
the main campus like five minutes in my
building and there's another indoor pool
but it's the other side of town it's
really weird sighs it's like twenty one
point something meters it's weird so
yeah I think this is going to become a
fixture of future lunch times so this
afternoon I'm going to be continuing to
try to fix the bloody sneaker I'm going
to be continuing to try and fix my code
now the problems been the vertical so
you're working with climate data you
have to quantize it which I mean you're
like considering variables like
temperature of brush or whatever on a
grid in the horizontal where you like
consider the like the points it's pretty
obvious you just do it in last year's
longitude but in the vertical it's a
little bit more complicated perhaps the
most intuitive is doing in s the height
above the surface this is something that
I tried with my model but um terrain
makes that a bit difficult the most
common choice is to do
pressure basically saying I'm going to
look at data on the thousand heads
ten nine seven five pets Pascal's 950
and an oil all the way up to one net
Pascal in the stratosphere this is what
I'm currently doing before I also try
our isentropic coordinates cross
potential temperature entropy and last
week I spent a lot of time coding Sigma
coordinates which is why pressure
coordinates but it's got a bit of the
zetz
in that each of these systems so
considering days out and constant Z
comes to be constant e to a constant
Sigma R they have their advantages and
disadvantages and I was kind of hoping
that by doing a non-standard thing that
it would fix the problems I've been
having which is if you need to the
challenge in or PV inversion is like the
whole video about it or your card out
here somewhere so I'm trying to invert
PV and get fields out and I can test how
well I'm doing that by considering the
derivatives of the output stream
function so if you look at the
derivatives and in the flat horizontal
direction so considering how your outlet
changes your very last two you very long
with you that gives you the lhasa T and
that's been pretty good actually the
velocities that we've been predicting
have been consistently fine if not
perfectly it's not perfect models I
would expect the problems been the
vertical derivatives because the
vertical derivatives corresponds to the
temperature and pressure coordinates for
example the derivative of the output our
stream function with respect to pressure
so I had changes when you're looking at
you know 958 Pascal's vs. about a net
Pascal's and you scale it by some other
factors that gives you the temperature
and that's been consistently woefully
bad like in an earlier vlog we were
having negative temperatures and not
only were they negative Kelvin
temperatures they were negative by like
a thousand degrees at the surface and by
naught point five degrees at the top of
the atmosphere and then like going from
- not by 5 Kelvin to naught point 5
Kelvin at the top so completely not
where you see in the atmosphere you know
you're looking for like 250 kind of that
vague area so like I said up and try out
all these different coordinates and I've
eventually come back to the industry
standard pressure coordinates what I
realized is that there's something
missing basically the problem that I
think has been happening up until
is that I have been imposing boundary
conditions at the bottom at the top but
I hadn't actually considered how much
mass there is an atmosphere I think I
kind of assumed that this would just
carry through in the other equations but
I realize now like I think it has so
today and yesterday I would write
scripts that basically kind of force the
the levels of the atmosphere so so
basically before I would allow the
program so you have all of these levels
in the atmosphere basically spelling off
by assuming they're all of the same
place and then they expand out with a
certain mass in between you know each
eatin layer which I could calculate oh
I'm not being trusted and that that
would just naturally spring back to the
kind of default values you see in the
atmosphere because you're forcing it
with what the amateur is forced by Mike
the rotation of the earth but it turns
out that's not correct so basically what
I've been doing is writing in a loop in
my code that says at the end of each
iteration saying well you know what's
the mean distance between these two
between our two sets of layers and
saying right well the average should be
this that's what you observed the
atmosphere so as this much to everydays
point on that particular level and then
that doesn't affect the horizontal
derivatives which as before were fine
and they are still fine what I'm now
done is managed to get the vertical
derivatives so basically how like you
will value your output from this day's
point here for example and how it
compares to the output at the point
directly below it I thought the next
pressure settles down now now looking a
lot better but they're not quite right
because for example and the pole is
currently warmer than the equator under
my output which obviously isn't right
while I was close then
and that's not just the case of changing
a minus sign or something comes from
deeper going wrong but actual progress
like I said at the start of this log so
like I'm finally getting there
lady how so tight turns out that you
know suing Mac as you but the show must
go on so up here I am thinking about
wanting a code tomorrow and how I'm
going to sort of get the output from my
inverter that bit closer to what we need
and right actually rewriting it now in a
fast language so I've been working in
Python up until now and I'm going to
change it to Fortran but down here when
the fingers editing time VidCon vlogs
baby normally have a plan I have no plan
I've no idea I'm doing this video help
[Music]
you